I
DID NOT KNOW THAT ABOUT YOU.
A >> Bret: HAVE A GOOD
WEEKEND.
♪ ♪
>> Jesse: ANYONE WHO HAS
PLAYED CARDS BEFORE AND KNOWS
THAT THERE ARE RULES TO THE
TABLE, YOU DON'T SPLASH THE POT,
YOU DON'T CHEAT, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY...
>> LISTEN, HERE'S THE THING, IF
YOU CAN'T SPOT THE SUCKER IN
YOUR FIRST HALF HOUR AT THE
TABLE, THEN YOU ARE THE SUCKER.
>> Jesse: MOST THE TIME THE
SUCKER DOES NOT EVEN REALIZE
THEY ARE THE SUCKER UNTIL IT'S
TOO LATE.
AND DEMOCRATS RIGHT NOW ARE
SITTING AROUND THE MIDTERM POKER
TABLE REALIZING THEY ARE THE
SUCKER.
THEY ARE OUT OF CHIPS, THEY ARE
OUT OF IDEAS, AND THEY ARE
SWEATING THROUGH THEIR SHIRTS.
AND WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE NERVOUS,
THEY HAVE TO MAKE EVERYBODY
AROUND THEM NERVOUS TOO.
>> DEMOCRACY IS ON THE BALLOT
HERE IN AMERICA.
>> DEMOCRACY AS WE KNOW IT MAY
NOT SURVIVE.
>> THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO PLAN TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE GOING AFTER DEMOCRACY.
>> ONE FINAL WARNING ON THIS
ISSUE TO MAKE VERY CLEAR AND
LEAVE NO DOUBT THAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE OUT THERE STILL PEDALING
THE BIG LIE.
>> Jesse: GUYS, THIS IS IT, WE
HAVE BEEN WARNED AND WHAT THE
COUNTRY WILL LOOK LIKE AFTER THE
RED WAVE?
NAZI GERMANY.
>> THIS COUNTRY IS ON TRACK TO
REPEAT WHAT HAPPENED IN GERMANY
WHEN IT WAS THE GREATEST
DEMOCRACY GOING AND ELECTED A
CHANCELLOR WHO THEN CO-OPTED TO
THE MEDIA.
>> Jesse: STILL NOT SCARED?
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT ABOUT A CIVIL WAR STARTED
BY A WHITE CHRISTIAN MEN?
>> THE GROUPS THAT START CIVIL
WARS ESPECIALLY ETHNICALLY BASED
CIVIL WARS ARE THE GROUPS THAT
HAD ONCE BEEN DOMINANT AND ARE
IN DECLINE.
YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES, THE GROUP THAT
HAD BEEN DOMINANT SINCE THE VERY
INCEPTION OF OUR COUNTRY WERE
WHITE MEN, THEY ALSO TENDED TO
BE CHRISTIAN, AND TODAY ARE
LOSING THAT POSITION.
IT IS NO LONGER GUARANTEE THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO GET INTO THE
BEST SCHOOLS OR GET THE BEST
JOBS OR HAVE COMMUNAL, ECONOMIC
SECURITY.
>> Jesse: SO IF REPUBLICANS
WIN THE HOUSE ON THE SENATE IT
WILL BE NAZI GERMANY WITH THEIR
WHITE CHRISTIAN MALE CIVIL WAR
ON THE SIDE.
THAT SOUNDS PRETTY BAD.
BUT HOW EXACTLY DO WE GO FROM
DEMOCRACY TO CIVIL WAR
NAZI GERMANY?
WELL, CHRIS HAYES WHO IDENTIFIES
AS RACHEL MADDOW EXPLAINS.
>> WHEN DEMOCRATS SAY YOU DON'T
HAVE A CHOICE THIS ELECTION,
THERE'S ONLY ONE PARTY THAT THEY
CARE ABOUT DEMOCRACY IS US AND
DEMOCRACY IS ON THE BALLOT, WHAT
THEY ARE REALLY SAYING IS IF YOU
DON'T SELECT US THIS TIME, IF
YOU DON'T KEEP THEM OUT OF
POWER, YOU MAY NEVER BE ABLE TO
ELECT US AGAIN OR IN SHORT VOTE
TO PRESERVE YOUR RIGHT TO THROW
THE BUMS OUT.
>> Jesse: SO RACHEL IS SAYING
IF REPUBLICANS WIN IT WILL BE
THE LAST ELECTION IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
I WILL MISS THAT IOWA CAUCUS, SO
GET READY FOR MITCH McCONNELL
TO LOCK HIMSELF IN HIS OFFICE
AND PUSH ALL THE VOTING MACHINES
INTO THE OCEAN.
BUT I'M GETTING THE FEELING
THERE IS A LITTLE PROJECTION
GOING ON HERE.
DEMOCRACY DIES IF WE DON'T HAVE
ONE PARTY RULE?
KEEP ONE PARTY RULE IN
WASHINGTON SO THAT WE CAN NUKE
THE FILIBUSTER AND KILL THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND PACKED THE
COURTS.
IT'S ILLEGAL TO SAY THAT THE
SYSTEM IS RIGGED, SO VOTE FOR US
SO WE CAN BREAK THE SYSTEM.
>> VOTING RIGHTS WILL PASS
ELECTION REFORM AND MAKE SURE NO
ONE, NO ONE EVER HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STEAL AN ELECTION
AGAIN.
>> Jesse: AGAIN!
DEMOCRATS ARE OKAY WITH ONE
PARTY RULE IF THEY ARE THE ONES
RUNNING IT.
REMEMBER THE BLACK PANTHERS
SWINGING BILLY CLUBS OUTSIDE OF
VOTING STATIONS WHEN BARRY WAS
ON THE BALLOT.
THAT'S A LITTLE INTIMIDATING,
RIGHT?
BUT THE BARACK SWINGMAN DROPPED
THE CHARGES AND SHOWED UP AT
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH'S HOME TO TRY
TO ASSASSINATE HIM IN FRONT OF
HIS FAMILY.
AND REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE IN
NORTH CAROLINA JUST GOT HIS
PARENTS HOUSE SHOT UP IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT WITH HIS
KIDS SLEEPING INSIDE.
>> MY PARENTS ARE WATCHING TV AT
11:00 AT NIGHT, JUST SITTING IN
THEIR LIVING ROOM AND A BULLET
CRACKS THROUGH THEIR HOME ONLY
20 FEET AWAY FROM WHERE MY KIDS
WERE SLEEPING THAT NIGHT.
THIS IS POLITICS AT ITS WORST.
AS A FORMER GREEN BERET, I'M
USED TO GETTING SHOT AT.
I'M OKAY WITH GETTING SHOT AT,
I'M NOT OKAY WITH MY FAMILY
GETTING SHOT AT.
>> Jesse: A DEMOCRAT FILM THE
CAMPAIGN COMMERCIAL IN FRONT OF
THAT REPUBLICANS HOUSE AND DAYS
LATER SOMEBODY SHOT A BULLET
THROUGH THE WINDOW.
NOW IF A BULLET HITS A
REPUBLICANS HOUSE, IT'S PROBABLY
A STRAY, BUT IF THAT WAS A
DEMOCRATS HOUSE, THAT WOULD'VE
BEEN AN ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT,
CNN, MSNBC, THE BROADCAST
NETWORKS DID NOT EVEN COVER THE
STORY.
THE ONLY COVER HAMMER ATTACKS.
BUT WHEN KATIE HOBBS CAMPAIGN
OFFICE WAS BROKEN INTO IN
ARIZONA, THE MEDIA FRAMED
REPUBLICAN CARY LAKE AS A
CRIMINAL.
AND WHEN THEY FOUND OUT IT WAS
AN ILLEGAL ALIEN THAT BROKE INTO
HOBBS OFFICE, THEY GO QUIET AND
TALK ABOUT THE BIG LIE.
DEMOCRATS JUST EXPECT YOU TO
BELIEVE ANYTHING THEY TELL YOU.
AND DON'T YOU DARE CHALLENGE
THEM FOR ALL THEIR DEMOCRACY
TALK, A BUNCH OF DEMOCRATS WON'T
EVEN DEBATE.
YOU KNOW WHAT A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY IS?
FRAMING YOUR OPPONENT FOR A
CRIME THEY DID NOT COMMIT AND
REFUSING TO DEBATE THEM IN FRONT
OF VOTERS.
>> WHY NOT DEBATE YOUR OPPONENT
IF YOU BELIEVE YOUR OPPONENT
IS -- HAS ISSUES AND IS
SPREADING CONSPIRACY THEORIES
ABOUT A STOLEN ELECTION AND SO
ON AND IS NOT BEING TRUTHFUL
WITH THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA, WHY
DO THEY NOT DO THAT ON THE
DEBATE STAGE AND TO DEBATE HER?
>> OUR CAMPAIGN STRATEGY IS OUR
CAMPAIGN STRATEGY.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK IT WAS NOT
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO SEE A
DEBATE IN THIS ELECTION FOR
GOVERNOR AT ALL.
>> WE ARE SIX DAYS FROM THE
ELECTION AND THIS IS THE
DECISION THAT WE MAD